no I am NOT what number am I thinking
about between 33 and 55 that number was
46 and Andy French got it by default
they're gonna be five-minute games
unless you say otherwise I will play
faster time controls if you'd like here
we go
the English copycat variation okay it's
going to declare one of these puns okay
well what's this probably gonna do now
one or two steps I'm gonna go with this
I'm gonna look to go with this typical
idea of getting in a 3 B 4 essentially
convert trying to converge my
LightSquared Bishop and rook on that b7
square so let's get rolling I also like
too many times in the English to
maintain my central pawns at their and
their home squares retain the
flexibility if this pawn goes again well
that clearly there's been time lost and
this is actually worth considering maybe
maybe this plan isn't so great I would
need two moves well yeah a three rook
here pawn push it could be prevented
with a five but that's not without
allowing me to camp out on b5 for a
while my concern is that am I is my
opponent going to just strike in the
center and make this plan look silly
eight three before I could just go with
the d4 and still I'm pretty sure claim
some advantage I'm gonna try that
because you know what I see that this
bishop is going to be problematic for
black especially with this Bishop Rd on
its long diagonal trying to get it
trying to fee and kettle it's going to
be quite difficult and notice after the
recapture there's already an issue on c6
so something like this I think would
fail to Knight to b5 and then D six
starts to get hammered
addition I could put more fuel on it and
I might want to now transition or I
might want to now focus my attention on
this D six point so night here I think
will eventually force my opponent to
have to play e5 and I I'm seeing a
strategical I don't know if you'd say
when but this is I think going to be a
very difficult situation now for black
because you could defend d6
okay and that wasn't being defended but
even if it was Bishop d6 induces this
advance although maybe night there would
be available I was thinking if I would
be needed and then I'll go to g5 take
out this Knight and then jump into this
square but now I'm just netting upon and
the bishop pair so this is gonna be
trouble right right around is there any
compensation there isn't my queen cannot
hang around here my opponent has to
simplify the position and that's
something I'm completely welcome to
Queen East seven I think I do best to
just develop why not just develop
okay and now I could place my opponent
in a pin Queen takes Knight takes bishop
here my opponent will get out of it is
there any good follow-up I can also grab
that pawn
maybe I want to do that I'm gonna go for
that
pin the knight first after rook here
after I've tied my opponent up just a
little bit only then will I grab here
rook here would be forced as otherwise
rook d8 is met with Bishop to c7 and
then I get a I get the exchange so I
could pick off another pawn there is no
rip b8 to grab the heart of my queen
side structure of these three this guy
is a without him these guys become a
very weak both bytes isolated so rook a
seven is only and now I'm going to drop
back not all the way is there anything
better let's just go here so I negate
this Knight
maybe he would want to make use of g4 at
least this is ruled out and if my king
is ever in check I just bump up to g2 so
I'm looking to just simplify the
position now Bishop here rook c7 I end
up dropping c4 I don't want this night
to play here that's going to be awkward
for my light square bishop so I think I
can just preserve my dark square bishop
and just get all my pieces working so
look up to d1 I already have a flight
square my opponent is still needing to
spend some time to get a flight square
these this is the past pawn on c4 can I
just get him pushing right away maybe I
probably could but I like to actually
just keep these guys strung together in
a2 through c4 structure and just get on
the D file pile up on the D not much
else beyond that what are my opponents
candidate moves this rook is frozen
actually these bishops are are crushing
this rook
that's that's tough okay so my night is
a little bit loose okay but my bishops
there to defend so this is intact I
guess the only the only way to be a bit
disruptive is to trying I don't know
would you call it a minority attack a5
a4 if I don't have to worry about any of
my pawns then my opponent really is just
not going to have anything I guess f6 is
being prepped Bishop back he 5 and then
this Knight has an outpost and I really
liked it I don't like that let's not
fall back on the clock
actually who can no I was just thinking
I could go here and this Bishop is
unprotected that's not it's not true
okay I'm just gonna do this and in
response to f6 I'm just going to give
that Bishop up I'm okay with this this
is probably the best or well how should
I say if this is the night that I want
to make sure it does not jump into this
Square still up two pawns no need to get
crazy I like to just play these
positions out where I don't have to
calculate I don't have to go through
these I don't want to I'm trying to just
keep control over the position maybe
that's the way to say don't let it get
out of hand in fact pawn push I could
take the bishop and then follow up with
the Bishop to g4 with the skewer I would
just be simplifying things more so I'm
gonna take this and now just jump in pin
the knight enough to worry about that
tricky night and now this idea this this
idea of a five a four stuff that I was
speaking of a little bit ago it's no
longer available form that battery last
piece involved it's no longer there my
Knights always there to just jump into a
four so there's no activity for the
rooks and this Knight just having a
tough day so
hmm there is the possibility for a night
here interfering with the communication
of the pieces okay how do I make
progress how about I just call me
playback and avoid any trouble it's not
really going to matter but I I'm just
going here to make sure everything is
connected in fact in this position right
here everything is protecting everything
I'm looking for a king improvement at
this point
alright let's get my pawn rolling get my
king to e3 or d3 we might have a knight
ending
let's go for it King the time to move
with the king whoa let me make sure I
stop this King if he was getting here he
would have two entry points so I want to
just shoulder that King off pawn push I
don't know if I even want to capture
I'll probably just push that night away
and then push up okay so I'm finding a
King and pawn endgame this is just a
winning King and pawn endgame again I'm
still up these two ponds so this guy's
gonna get rolling no way to stop that
inch by inch and I can actually just let
those guys sit and come over in this
direction many different ways to go
about victory so now this is going to be
a target I want to put pressure on that
okay I want to open stuff up almost like
it - rook open up some files open up
some squares really excuse me there's
nothing to do okay the game Andy let's
back up and try and take something away
from this quickly okay so what what's
the first thing that jumped out at me
I think I think this turns out to be a
favorable structure for me being able to
eventually play against d6 which fell on
the game the majority the game was
played where my opponent was down the
pond so I'm drawn back to this the
points leading up to that pond falling
of course and so I actually questioned a
little bit the decision to make a pond
move at this stage I've seen here's a
here's an interesting deployment of this
King Knight I've seen instead of I mean
hang on for a second what did you do
okay you didn't end up doing a king side
fiend cut out but that's certainly
something you could be doing you could
still be going with I was gonna say you
could still be going at the copycat game
as if like I'm already on this square
but nevertheless you could be going with
the King side fianchetto and you could
be looking to reroute this King Knight
to the d4 square now how could you do
that look at just um consider this
potential this line here g6 Bishop g7
with Knight h6 to f5 he's sidelined for
just a moment but once he's on f5 he's
contributing to central control in a
great way and he is also staying clear
of your bishop on that long diagonal so
it's just at least another setup you
could look to implement again g6 Bishop
g7 and play Knight h6 to f5 I'm somehow
reminded of a game between Luke McShane
and Luke McShane and who was playing
white against I just can't remember
does anybody know I think there was a
pretty popular game look McShane it
wasn't against Magnus Carlsen was it
does anybody recall like this sort of
opening where Luke's opponent played
Knight h6 and there was this d4 advance
and Luke ended up giving up his bishop
or something does that ring about
I don't know I'm looking in the chat
right now to see it might have ok so
there's maybe there's a thought at least
from Fineman Dirac for that it was
kramnik I just I can't remember it might
it might have been him but I know it was
um I know was against a strong player so
it could have certainly been Vladimir
Kramnik but in the impending event it's
it's another another thing to look into
night age six again looks very awkward
but now h6 - f5 and you're really keying
in on that d4 square it's not the only
way you can go about again just a little
bit of insight about another setup you
could also just play e5 here and try to
cover this cover that try and try and
make sure that this well no no no no
this I don't know if you want to really
give up that d5 square so easily as soon
as you do e five that's weak and so
maybe you could just go with the
kingside fiend cut oh yeah maybe maybe
that's better than this c6 advance look
into this move even at this at this
stage instead of east 6 to 2 have a nice
structure and even even if you're able
to defend this pawn think it's very
troublesome again Queen b8 Bishop here
if you move the pawn you give me this
square light square issues you have and
you might you know you need to do
something like Knight to e5 I'm just not
quite sure it seems very uncomfortable
for black right here because of this
deep on on a half-open file that starts
to become a big issue that's really the
main point because right from here it's
just a matter of technique I mean ended
up netting another pawn it wasn't I
don't know that there was really an
opportunity
to capitalize on the moves I was making
once I was up some material okay I said
I believe more than enough that game so
again good one
Andy he's close